So remember the stunt Donald Trump pulled
Sunday, uh, showing up at a church and the
White House said that he showed up to pray
for the victims of the shooting, the mass
shooting that took place in Virginia last
week or on Friday.
Last Friday.
Um, president Trump showed up to a church
and um, it was apparently not a, as the pastor
is now reporting, they did not show up to
pray for, uh, the victims of the mass shooting.
Uh, but instead to pray for the president
himself, you have to be some kind of scumbag
to lie about the reason that you're praying,
especially when you're supposed to be praying
for the victims.
I mean, the, all Republicans do in a mass
shooting or after a mass shooting is to offer
thoughts and prayers.
But apparently the president of the United
States isn't even offering prayers.
Genuinely.
Here's a quote from the article in the Huffington
Post says, quote, a pastor's explanation of
President Donald Trump sudden visit to his
church on Franklin Graham's pray for Donald
Trump's day is casting doubt on the White
House.
It's widely publicized claim that he went
there to pray for Friday's shooting victims
and Virginia Beach, David Platt, pastor of
Mclean Bible church, a few miles from Trump's
golf course in northern Virginia, wrote in
a statement that he first heard about Trump's
visit after he finished his sermon early Sunday
afternoon.
So much to unpack there that's actually worthwhile.
First of all in the hell are we having a national
pray for Trump day that I can write an entire
book about why not only is that problematic,
but it's also, uh, it's also just a tool to
rally evangelical voters to the Republican
Party.
And it's been this, this symbiotic relationship
between the Evangelical Church and republicanism
since Ronald Reagan actually did write a book
about it.
And then I think about it, um, God is not
a Republican.
Um, but that, that part setting that part
aside, the fact that the president was still
in his golf outfit, his golf clothes, uh,
I, and, and he Westin really quick to get
a photo op praying for the victims of the
mass shooting.
But it ended up just turning out to be a prayer
for him.
I mean, there's layers and layers of hypocrisy.
It's already in the story.
But I want to read one more paragraph, uh,
from Huffington post and said, quote, the
White House though had given a different reason
for the visit.
Just as Trump was walking into the church,
the press office sent out a statement claiming
that he was there to visit the pastor and
pray for the victims and community of Virginia
Beach.
Yet during the entirety of Trump's 16 minutes
stay plat, the pastor did not mention the
shooting and Trump never spoke about the shooting
or anything else beyond thinking plat afterwards.
So I mean, I guess you could chalk this up
and say it was just, Oh, it's just a miscommunication.
Um, they didn't really convey the reason that
they were there.
I mean, if you want to be generous, sure you
can chalk that up and, but, but why does it
matter?
It matters because it's a, because it's a
very consistent theme with Donald Trump and
Republicans and conservatives in general,
all for different reasons.
It's a, it's a, it's a consistent theme with
Donald Trump to be habitual liar.
Right?
Um, he lies about everything, but particularly
he lies about his religion and his faith and
he presents himself or, you know, let, let
me take that back.
Evangelicals try to present Donald Trump as
some type of a reverent, a pious person who,
uh, is ordained by God to fix America when
in reality, Trump is just aligned.
Well, we're on David Show, so I can't use
profanity, but Trump is an outright liar about
his belief system, about politics, about his
ego.
I mean, it, there's no facet of Donald Trump's
life that he is not compelled to lie about.
And so this is just a really consistent theme
with Donald Trump.
He's also opportunistic.
I mean, he literally still had on his golf
shoes, you know, coming in, whisking in the
church.
Uh, there was a paragraph that I wanted to
read, but the church is actually the closest
church to the golf course.
So he didn't really say, okay, I'm going to
go to Virginia so that I can pray for these
people.
What actually happened was he realized, or
an assistant realized that Donald Trump is
in Virginia and in Virginia Beach and he's
not there on behalf of the victims.
He's there to play golf.
How do we fix it?
Well, you have some enterprising assistant
who says, okay, what we can do is let's shoot
over to the local church and say a prayer
for the victims.
But they didn't relay that information to
the pastor.
See how that works.
So not only does Donald Trump a liar, he's
opportunistic and really quite frankly, did
not care about those victims enough to realize
that he was in Virginia and hadn't really
done anything but except go golfing.
And then somebody tried to fix a problem,
ultimately making the problem even worse.
The story is also significant because of what
I was discussing with Franklin Graham, uh,
with the Evangelical Movement.
Absolutely trying to spin Donald Trump to
be something more than this.
Uh, this, this, I really only have a religious
word.
This lascivious, uh, this, this disgusting
man who was driven by nothing but his ego
and his passions.
Who is the exact opposite of everything evangelicals
preach.
Donald Trump is the exact opposite of everything
that evangelicals preach, but because he is
their political tool, Donald Trump is there
political pawn.
They're willing to give him a Mulligan to
use some golf term terminology.
forget about all of the different ways Donald
Trump demonstrates that he is absolutely the
opposite of anything Jesus would have been
or do.
But evangelicals don't care about that.
They care about their political agenda.
Most of their political agenda, it's about
taking away a woman's right to choose attacking
the Lgbtq community and marriage equality.
They don't care about anything else, but those
things, they don't care about any other form
of morality.
They don't care about economic justice.
They don't care about oppression.
And, uh, what capitalism does to poor people,
they don't care about children after they're
born.
They don't care about any of that.
Donald Trump is great to them because Donald
Trump gives them an opportunity to do everything
they want on a particularly on taking away
a woman's right to choose.
So as far as evangelicals are concerned, Donald
Trump probably could shoot somebody on fifth
avenue and still be one of their favorite
presidents.
Um, and the last thing, and not to, not to
Belabor the point too much, but this idea
of praying for the president when in fact
the last administration they prayed against
the president, uh, shows the hypocrisy that
they're not operating in terms of any sense
of real, any real sense of faith and being
concerned about the leadership of our country.
They're only concerned about the leadership
of this country that serves their political
interests.